Oh
you
I'll try to keep
the warmest of welcomes to you we await
the conclusion of the pregame
formalities
I'm Peter Drury and here with me in the
commentary box on Platts report is Jim
Begley well thank you very much mr.
Drury and hello to everyone
and the action is back on the way
bill mil then and we're back on the way
that's very far from making something
happened by himself lovely to see Hector
berry
oxlade-chamberlain Ramsey
Mertesacker gets it back wonderful quick
feet to broy
that's one way of trying to make things
happen there's a few who could follow
that example nari
yes Kozel
and it's shiru shiru with the ball
through
which is gone that's a foul
that's going to be a booking is a gather
ground and they are clearly concerned
charge to to liver ball into the box
decent hit from there
we'll rail
Ramzi that's clearly not what he wanted
to do miss ghazal he's pulled them up to
that challenge
that's a booking always looked in it's
like he's picked up a bit of a lot from
that challenge
they just nervous we're still waiting
for a goal to report here to Broin now
it's mastery he's off on a marauding run
Ramsey
Hector buried play for a throw
it's also so what now
horse loose who's getting there L'Oreal
saw the letter cut it out
that had to be more accurate
Shirou Mesut özil
yes
we'll be a jury
so loose fall oxlade-chamberlain with
the delivery
you'd save really well-read
he's just nervous he was gonna make this
there's
and it's oxlade-chamberlain
hey sister bus
long left and still we await the
breakthrough now it's Shirou Mesirow
cell now churu churu passes it through
lore'l Shirou tries a fruit bowl
deployed
Ramsey since a free kick for that
he's going to have his name taken
he's feeling the effects of that tackle
Yaya touré if we're going to get a
winner it's got to come now
Fernan teen yo referees awarded a free
kick
that's going to be a booking
and it's nervous it's one lacking in
accuracy that's understandable because
they haven't found that easy against
this defense and shooting from that sort
of range it's not the answer
Nasri gets it back
he's just nervous sap a lesson
- bro
satellizer hey sis nervous
there's a Tercel very firm in standing
his ground there it is a tough
full-contact contest
look I don't think he can say he didn't
have enough support in that instance
because it's got to get his head up more
and see what's around it's been taken
down and the referee has pointed at the
spot Arsenal been given a penalty
eyeball-to-eyeball with the goalkeeper
never any doubt
never in doubt on the keeper certainly
guessed right but there was enough time
to target arsenal tech blade one lil ya
been awarded the penalty is one thing
now but finding the net under so much
pressure at this stage of affairs is
another so a big well done from a for me
certainly for keeping a cool head
Coquelin arsenal just had to run down
the clock it's been intercepted and that
will come to nothing
now it's shiru shiru tries to stroke it
through
Yaya touré de Bruyne
Bernadino will chose there will be three
extra minutes
aimed forward looking to force his way
through Shirou with the ball through
he'll have at it and with that the final
whistle Arsenal win it by the only goal
result no question the most important
thing however it came final score
one nil